now I want to allay the fears of some in
our audience about this entire Trump not
accepting the results thing uh Donald
Trump at the last debate when asked
would you accept the results of the
upcoming election will you accept them
here is what he had to say your running
mate governor pence pledged on Sunday
that he and you his words will
absolutely accept the result of this
election today your daughter Ivanka said
the same thing I want to ask you here on
this stage tonight do you make the same
to them until you will absolutely sir
that you will absolutely accept the
result of this election I will look at
it at the time I'm not looking at
anything now I'll look at it at the time
what I've seen what I've seen is so bad
first of all the media is so dishonest I
want to be super clear here so that we
can all understand while what Donald
Trump is saying is nonsense it's totally
inconsequential nonsense refusing to
accept the election results it might
inspire action from Republicans it might
lead his supporters into the streets to
violently protest it might cause
Republican voters to consider Hillary
Clinton an illegitimate president much
like many of them have president obama
for the last eight years but it will not
actually make any difference legally it
makes no difference whether Donald Trump
accepts the results or concedes and
gives a speech in 43 states the
candidate who loses can petition for a
recount of the votes in that state in
about half of those 43 states if there's
a really small Bob margin an automatic
recount will be triggered but ultimately
this doesn't matter Pat the identity of
the new president is going to be
certified by the House and Senate where
the electoral votes will be formally
delivered in early January it gets
signed off on by the Senate President
Trump not conceding might be politically
interesting but it will not have actual
consequences but what does matter is how
his supporters perceive him not
conceding and they decide to take to the
streets and go after Hillary Clinton
over this no doubt about it the the
biggest consequences will
will what happens on november nine and
it could be a trump win but it seems
more likely if it's a loss will what
Donald Trump does lay down november
eighth or early on november nine is it
going to inspire his supporters to get
out into the street and commit commit
acts of violence is it going to inspire
the feeling that Hillary Clinton if
elected is not a legitimate president in
some way we know what that's like
because we've had eight years of it
under Obama by the way as I mentioned
that's really the question but if your
concern is that Trump not conceding
might in some way hinder Hillary
Clinton's ability to actually be sworn
in as president of the United States if
indeed she wins don't worry about that
and what we do know is that early voting
is happening more than ever before it
started yesterday in many states
including in the important swing state
Florida it started yesterday here in
Massachusetts I'm not voting early Pat
are you are you voting early my plan is
to vote early yes probably on Friday
okay yeah I I mean I could have but I
feel like I should just go in on
november eighth this so i can be part of
the whole thing and then we come in and
do the show on the eighth i can say hey
i just came in from voting and it can
actually be true because i'd rather all
else being equal i'd rather tell the
truth on the show but a lot of people
voting early and Democrats
over-represented in early voting in a
lot of states and the other good thing
about voting on Election Day for you too
is you can see if there is a group of
Trump supporters yeah after casting
their ballot that are going around and
trying to intimidate you and others yet
you know based on where I live I don't
exactly live in the most historically
liberal neighborhood in Boston although
it is changing now if you're going to
have angry Trump supporters uh it very
well may be in my neighborhood but I
don't want to get ahead of myself we
will see on november eighth what happens
let's take a break of course you can
discuss any of these stories suggest
stories suggest guests for the show on
our reddit discussion forum which you
can find by going to david pakman.com
slash reddit which is of course our e DD
IT gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video
games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s